foreign
[Music]
has existed for 45 million centuries
but this one is special
it's the first when one species as as
the planet's future in his hands
full of Earth's history threats have
come from nature
disease earthquakes asteroids and so
forth
but from now on
the worst
dangers come from us
[Music]
and is now not just the nuclear threat
in our interconnected World Network
breakdowns can Cascade globally
air travel can spread pandemics
worldwide within days
and social media can spread panic and
rumor literally at the speed of light
we fret too much about Minor hazards
in powerful air crashes
Carthage engine food low radiation Doses
and so forth
and our political Masters are in denial
about catastrophic scenarios
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
[Music]
welcome everybody out there in the wide
world of astrophysics cosmology
philosophy and really and understanding
anyone who has an understanding and a
desire to know more about our natural
world and the place that science holds
within it you're in for a treat talking
to a great friend not only of a UCSD
science and other phenomena but really a
hero of mine and many of the really the
most proficient I would say working
theorists and and cosmology really look
to Martin Lord Martin Reese today's
guest uh for inspiration and for really
a voice of reason and uh you know
continually troubled age so Lord Martin
thank you so much for joining us from
the UK how are you today sir I'm fine
it's great to be in touch with you again
it is and I love all of your books I've
read all of your books you you blurbed
one of my books and we'll get to that
later because today is Nobel Prize day
week kicks off it's I call it Christmas
for nerds and we both have perspectives
on including in this book and we'll get
to the contents of this book and we'll
talk about many other things along the
way and we'll probably run out of time
before we run out of topics as we often
do um it's just it's just such an honor
Martin to speak with you but I want to
do what I'm told that you should never
do which is to judge a book by its cover
you're just not supposed to do that
that's considered poor form but I always
say what else do you have to go on uh
besides the cover and the title uh and
so I always ask my authors who honor me
by coming on the podcast I ask them as I
ask you now what was the Genesis the
origin story behind this magnificently
Illustrated cover but more importantly
behind the title that you chose for this
wonderful new book so Martin if you
could indulge Us in what I call judging
books by their covers well
I am going to escape my answer by saying
if both of them were chosen by my editor
that's about 80 of the time I hear that
answer all right yes I was uh not so
sure about the title
um but I think a playing cover is okay
yeah so I'm not unhappy with it
um when I I read the title so the title
if science is to save us there's a lot
loaded into that uh title so can you can
you walk us through the meaning of the
title
um yes well my theme really is that uh
uh our everyday world has only come
about because of the science of the last
century or two but science is now uh
more empowering and that has both good
and bad possibilities so the stakes are
very high and what we could do obviously
is to harness science and provide a
better life for everyone in the world
than we in the west have at the moment
on the other hand there are disasters
which can be triggered by the
misapplication of science so the stakes
are getting higher this is a theme I've
talked about in the past but I feel more
and more concerned but in this book I
discuss not only those concerns but the
scientific Community how it reacts to uh
threats
um how it interacts among itself and the
interaction between science and politics
and The Wider public all of those are
important topics and I've had experience
in my later years of being involved in
scientific organizations and also
inhibition politics so the book is
really a mixture of uh science and how
it's applied and its social consequences
so when I first received the book uh I
couldn't help but thinking you know Lord
Martin as a member of the House of Lords
and this common refrain that I've never
really quite understood maybe you can
walk me through it
um God saved the queen uh and and uh I
couldn't help but be reminded of that
phrase it came into my mind and this is
in early mid-august when I received the
book and of course we're talking in
early October the queen sadly is no
longer with us I wondered if you could
explain or just what was your relation
you once joked with me and I I I steal
this joke but I usually give you
attributes I always give you attribution
because it can apply to anybody else but
you once told me as a joke that your job
as astronomer Royal was to tell the
queen her horoscope uh
so I can't I can't say I have ever done
that so I always give you attribution as
a good academic should but Martin what
was she like
um to what extent did you know her did
you get to know the personal side of her
and what does her passing mean not only
for the Great Britain but what does it
mean if anything to science itself yes
well let me say I I didn't know her
personally but I met her on a number of
occasions
um once or twice through being a
stronger but more often because I was a
member of some Elite body called the
order of Merit which had regular lunches
and uh when I was president of Rosa Sati
we celebrated our 350th anniversary and
it was quite a big Jamboree where we had
seven seven members of the royal family
there Etc so I had some contact but uh
normally in a sort of official context
so I wouldn't claim to have known her
but I think if you ask what her impact
was uh the fact that most people can't
remember a time when she wasn't around
as Queen indicates that she's been of
stable aspects of life in this country
despite all the changes and so it is
really the end of an era and of course
since she started as Queen very young
and
so for 70 years it's unlikely that we'll
ever in the next 200 years even if it
continues have uh someone serving for so
long
um
but it was a very special rain that she
uh and she managed to keep
the respect of everyone for all that
period yeah yeah I just think of her
with such great dignity my mother met
her uh back in sometime in the 60s for
you know 10 seconds but it had this
lifelong effect on her
um and uh and I wonder you know if if I
could pivot extremely quickly uh just to
a notion that I've had recently which is
the state of uh which runs throughout
this wonderful book the state of uh
science in the United Kingdom uh both on
the synoptic you know Grand overview but
but also down in the in the in the weeds
a little bit uh as you know the Great
British pound has has fallen
precipitously there's a new prime
minister as I understand it I don't know
how all these things work uh it's very
shadowy to us in the United States we
just have simple things like an
electoral college that's representative
based on gerrymandering that anyway I
don't want to get into U.S politics
um but um but we there's been a lot of
turmoil economically there's been brexit
there's been
um uh the new prime minister the the
overthrow of the previous prime minister
you know has has formed government has
dissolved and now your new prime
minister
um I've been thinking venally that now
might be a great time for U.S
institutions to kind of scoop up The
Best of British talent uh in that we can
offer maybe you know a slightly better
you know caliber of of monetary you know
performance for things like houses and
mortgages that are very important to
academicians you talk about salary and
funding scientists in this book
um am I wrong you know is it is it
should I be ashamed of these thoughts
Martin that I that I am thinking about
who could we poach from the United
Kingdom right now including you maybe uh
to come to a U.S institution uh possibly
to to LinkedIn or extend their careers
or make them more enjoyable and to
bolster the scientific reputation of the
US is this shameful Behavior by me well
you're being very patriotic but let me
just say why I don't resonate let me
first make clear I think the present
government is an embarrassing disaster
okay I get support exerted party but
this lot
um are heading off in the wrong
direction
um but the reason I don't resonate with
your view is that um I feel that their
problem is they are trying to ape the
U.S too much and it's far better to
learn more from Scandinavia which has
high tax
strong welfare state Etc and they move
away from that they admire what you're
doing here
um despite the fact that you have the
worst prison system in the western world
and the amazing gun prevalence Etc
um and they would do far better if they
were to uh uh learn from the countries
of Northern Europe in particular to have
good welfare states and a Quantum most
uh oppose the happiest people so they're
heading in the wrong direction
America has led them in the wrong
direction in my view well I have to take
well I've never I've never felt tempted
in fact uh when I was um 30 I got a top
profession but Cambridge and I then got
office and two of the American
universities which I declined of course
um but I never got any offers since then
you could have thought my work declined
after the age of 30 but I think more
likely they realized that I was not
likely to want a defect to the US right
and having said that though I would like
to acknowledge all that I've benefited
from by short visits to the US the main
centers and of course I've gotten many
friends at La Jolla and I've written
papers with seven of the faculty at
Santa Cruz and also with many in other
places like like Princeton and uh and
Harvard yeah many many academic
connections but in terms of living there
um uh outside Academia I've never been
tempted at all well uh I just I want to
be respectful but I have to say one of
the issues and this is getting deep into
the weeds for my U.S uh uh listeners but
but for my UK I have a sizable audience
in the UK I love the audience I'm going
to visit them and maybe do an event
there next year in 2023 uh but uh one of
the uh one of the organizations you
criticize in this uh wonderful book is I
think the ukri which again you you kind
of um say is aping too much of the U.S
kind of men but I want to be extremely
uh show my extreme gratitude to ukri
because they have just funded the United
Kingdom participation in the Simon's
Observatory to the attune of many many
you know tens of millions of pounds or
dollars I guess we'll say here and and
that's to enable transformative science
in the very field that you helped to
kick off which is the science of CMV
polarization so so Mark don't be too
hard on your kri okay they're they're
paying you know no it's it's good and of
course we have good scientists in this
field and and I think it's very
important also to realize that uh
despite brexit which was a disaster for
the UK
um we remain in the great European
consortia the European Southern
Observatory which is building the
world's largest telescope 39 meters
diameter
um and uh the European Space Agency
which has had no exciting projects like
the Planck spacecraft which you
obviously know about and so
unfortunately despite brexit we remain
in those consortia
absolutely okay so let's go back to the
book uh Lord Martin the book um is a
exposition of the state of Science and
the limitations of science first I want
to start with the I want to go through
it almost talmudically as I want to do
and on occasion so science the word
science comes from as I understand the
Latin cientia which means knowledge it
does not mean wisdom which is Sapienza
uh which is uh why we're called Homo
sapiens and as I understand it I may be
wrong but the thing that we have wisdom
about sapience of is that we're going to
die we're the only creatures that are
aware that life is finite as smart as my
you know pet uh pet you know Pit Bull is
uh she doesn't know that she's gonna die
and I I wonder
um if we sometimes conflate the two uh
wisdom uh sapiens and knowledge science
um and and in this notion of saving and
kind of almost Messianic if that's
really the appropriate realm for
scientists to be expected to achieve
what do you think Martin
um do we put too much of a burden on
that word science and scientists
well no I think science itself
as you say is ethically neutral
um but the point is that uh it can be
applied for benefit or in a damaging way
and the ethical choices will determine
whether SARS does save us or destroy us
that's the whole point of the title
right so when science is sometimes
though conflated with scientists and you
make a clear distinction in this book
um of the limitations of that I guess I
wonder what Drew you to science what
what is
um I I interviewed your countrymen uh
Jim Al khalili not too long ago on the
publication this wonderful book The Joy
of science
um
we get a lot of pleasure out of science
most of us would do this job if we
didn't get paid for it don't tell my
Governor Gavin Newsom he's my boss and
and he will take advantage of you saying
that
um but what is it that attracts you to
science and and what is it that
scientists really need I mean we get to
you know we get paid not not incredibly
well by you know Wall Street standard
but we get paid a handsome salary even I
at a public university in the south of
California
um you know I'm very comfortable but um
and we get academic freedom we get
tenure and we get basically similar
things that were present a thousand
years ago when the University of Bologna
was started in the year 1080.
um what do what does society oh
scientists let me let me ask that
question if if if if us if we are to
save scientists is there an obligation
of a society to quote unquote save
scientists
um well I think if you look back over
the last hundred years uh we will see
that most of the uh benefits of everyday
life
um in health Communications transportal
rest can be traced back to um often sort
of
um undirected science
um and uh it's often said that
scientists have two kinds applied and
not yet applied
and so uh I think everyone can look back
and say that the investment made in
science and supporting scientists has uh
certainly proved itself a good
investment over the last uh Century or
not of course it's not so true if we go
back further because
um before the mid-19th century
um technology was quite separate I mean
they could build marvelous Cathedrals
and the steam engines Etc but that came
before any uh real science so it's only
since the mid-19th century we've had
this symbiosis between uh academic
science and its applications but I think
we can say that it has proved its worth
and of course the same people in the
universities who do the science
certainly in the system we have in your
country and mine they are the people who
also do the teaching and so an output of
our life's work is not just the research
we do but the students who we hope to uh
educate so that they can take part not
just in science but in other walks of
life where the background is crucial and
of course one of the themes of my book
later on is that everyone needs to have
some feel for science because so much of
the world depends on it and so many
decisions that we have to take as
Citizens whether they be on health
energy or the environment have a
scientific Dimension so science is
something which needs to percolate to
the wide public and we need to have the
experts to do that as well as to extend
the research and you've been you know
kind of a mentor as I say a hero however
you want to phrase it to me and many
millions of people around the world
um and part of that's because of your
you know really just tireless pursuit of
science Outreach and and expect station
which comes not only at the by way of
your extreme you know eloquent and uh
and wonderful you know capability to
deliver the message but also because you
have authenticity because of your great
scientific accomplishments in America
well I shouldn't say in America there
are people in other countries as well
but it's almost denigrated to some
extent I had um I have all these finger
puppets here uh Lord Martin indulge me
with some forbearance while I try to
find some of them uh I'm looking for
Carl Sagan I've got him somewhere in
here
um I'll put I'll put up a Galileo just
to to make uh the video Watchers happy
um so you know of course he was sort of
seemed like he was almost punished in
some ways he was a great scientist uh
and also he was a great communicator and
it's by some reckonings he received more
attention as a scientist by virtue of
the Cosmos series in 1980 uh than any
other scientist before or since because
now everything's so fractured there's 10
million cat videos uploaded to YouTube
every second
I'm told uh but now you know but back
then it was three channels here and I
remember watching it as a kid
um by what you know kind of you know
Tech tools or by by what mechanism could
we perhaps make it so that scientists
are not penalized or looked down upon uh
for for participating in the public
dialogue which I think we have a moral
obligation to do since we're getting
paid by the public we have to
communicate to the I mean imagine you
went to tell your Dean you know you
can't understand what I'm well you could
get away with it I couldn't get away
with it you don't you don't know what
I'm doing or you work at Apple and you
tell Tim Cook you can't understand what
I'm doing it it's beyond you you know as
Feynman said yeah if it was worth a
novel if I could explain it to you it
wouldn't have been worth a Nobel Prize
um but so Lord Martin can you tell us
what you know first of all did you
consciously set about in any way to
study the craft of communication
marketing you know in some way to that
that you know could teach the the true
wonderful script the greatest story ever
written in some ways did you ever study
the the mode by which you can
communicate it or are you just Predator
naturally gifted at that
well I'd like to go back and clear what
you were saying I mean uh I think it is
true and maybe true in America uh that
uh uh popularization was frowned on
um and I think it's disgraceful the way
the American National Academy was so
late in giving recognition to Carl Sagan
of whom I was an immense fan I thought
it was wonderful yeah um as we need more
people like that and I I think I say in
my book that uh uh we need people like
him to um uh lead campaigns found him
I'm sorry I found him and uh I had his
widow he was Nigerian has been has been
a guest on the podcast and his daughter
Sasha Sagan has been a guest podcast
it's a family Affairs
who's done the sort of uh updated
version yeah but uh I I think he was a
great guy um but if I think back to
myself I mean I um uh was brought over
in the University where um many of the
greatest figures had been popular Rises
especially in my subjects I mean Fred
Hoyle
um the road science fiction and uh he
was in my view for 25 years the world's
number one astrophysicist in terms of
range of ideas
um he went um a bit sort of eccentric in
his later years but he was a really
great man and thinking back
um to earlier Generations another of my
direct predecessors was Arthur Eddington
who was famous for his for his books and
so uh and I think in other fields people
like JBS holdain Bernal and other of
that kind
um got through to the wider public so I
think there was always a intermeshing of
wider culture with science in Britain
and I don't think it harms people's
reputation at all
so I'm sorry if that's the case in the
U.S yeah no there are you know there are
kind of yeah it's almost like well if
you are if you have time uh and you're a
scientist you know maybe you'll maybe
he'll teach and maybe he'll put some
energy into learning how to be a good
teacher in the you know modes of
pedagogy but you know really we pay you
to to do research and to get grants and
so forth and maybe we could pivot there
to you know Academia as I mentioned yeah
you have a lot of of opinions about
Academia and how to improve it both in
the UK and and elsewhere
um and the models thereof and and you
kind of reminded me of something uh
maybe I knew but I didn't really
remember and it's that really in other
countries like Germany uh in some places
in Asia and France they have dedicated
research institutes where the um
scientists work like Max Planck or crnrs
in France but only in in the uh you know
in the kind of other Western countries
maybe Italy and and then the UK and
England and America which all Trace back
to to Germany by uh ironically uh the
Humboldt uh institutes and so forth but
but how how it's possible like I don't
expect my airline pilot you know because
he's really good at or she's really good
at flying you know to be like an expert
meteorologist okay there's something to
do with meteorology and flying but you
know and I'm I fly little tiny planes
but but I'm not a meteorologist if I did
if I were a meteorologist San Diego is
the ideal place to do it Martin because
you know we basically have one weather
icon that we have to put up every day as
you know
um not so for our sports teams we we
don't have such good consistency but why
do we why do we come to expect that you
know because you're a good researcher
you'd be a good teacher I mean happens
to be true for people like Faraday and
and others but you know I don't know
that Dirac was a great teacher right so
um
on the other hand you know Feynman was
an amazing lecturer at least if you were
you know at a Nobel level caliber to
understand half of this stuff not a
freshman but um why do we do that why do
we assume that just because someone's
brilliant at research that they'll make
good teachers and then give them no
training on how to be a teacher and I've
received no training on pedagogy maybe
that's my fault but why do we assume
that you know because you're brilliant
in the lab or in the uh in the in the
computer or the theory uh space that
you'll be good at teaching yes
um well it's true that there's not a
good correlation particularly between
being good researcher and a good teacher
but nonetheless
um I think there is a virtue in the
research universities as you say the the
Germans have abandoned it but we have it
in the UK and the US and it's native
Chinese have adopted it to some extent
Singapore and it it I think um it does
have I would say two virtues first it
does mean that um the best students get
exposed even at the undergraduate level
um to the best researchers
um and that may be may be important in
stimulating them at the frontier as it
were
um but I think it also really uh has the
effect of uh ensuring that
the teachers the academics slightly
broaden their perspective
and I think there is a risk of excessive
narrowness in Academia and if they have
to teach you or talk to a public
audience it's broader um in fact I I
quote in my book the um uh the story of
Penzance and Wilson
um that uh um Will Wilson didn't realize
how important his Discovery was until he
read the article in the New York Times
by Walter Sullivan uh saying that what
they discovered was the Arctic though of
creation he'd been so worried about the
technicality hadn't realized that and so
that's an example where one does get a
better perspective if one does uh
explain one's work to a wider audience
so I think there's a lot to be said for
the research University but having said
that
um I think the model is being stressed
um and uh I wrote an article for British
magazine a couple of years ago
explaining what was going wrong because
in universities there's more did culture
promotion is slow Etc and the editor
entitled The the article why I'm young
why I'm not
so why I'm glad I'm not a young academic
yeah yeah
um and uh that's that's because if I
think of the time when I was starting
and this would have been true if I'd
been in America the same way
um to be in a burst of University
expansion in the 1960s
um the young outnumbered the old there
was still a retiring age and so
promotion was quite quick
um now uh there's far more of an audit
culture in both of our countries and
promotion is slow because there are so
many people and it's even worse actually
in the U.S in biomedical areas because
there was a survey a few years ago which
showed that the average age at which
people in those fields got their first
NIH Grant was 43 43 yeah not contrasted
with uh the earlier situation uh Shirley
Tillman who was the president of
Princeton and a champion of mine she
said that she did a PhD in three years
three years as a postdoc and then first
grant you can't do that now and My worry
is that because of this slow promotional
congestion in Academia there's a serious
problem because the ones who will stay
are the Nerds who can't do anything else
but we want to keep in Academia at least
some fraction of people who are
ambitious and flexible people who want
to feel they've achieved something
individually by their 30s and that's far
less possible Academia now than it was
and this is I think a big worry yeah and
I think it's because of the uh amount of
time people have to spend in Grant
applications because
um whereas until the 70s there was
expansion so the young have nobody old
that's no longer the case
yeah and I I've spoken with a few folks
I think I spoke to Jim alkalilee about
this and others about you know how to
rectify it and and some of it was you
know mandatory actual retirement I mean
we have people here uh I was showing you
before we uh before we started recording
you know I'm in uh Jeffrey burbridge's
old office here and I've got some of
Margaret burbages you know here's a
spectrum of a spiral galaxy which showed
Doppler shift that she ended up teaching
to Vera Rubin
um and then Vera Rubin while she was
here for a year learned from the the two
of them and and went on to great Fame
and success
um but I wanted to um to kind of you
know then again pivot once again back to
uh another Direction which is um which
is you know kind of the role of of
incentivization in science uh you talk a
little bit about you know citation
counts and all these metrics that we've
you know really only come about in
Earnest in the last you know few decades
and I'm thinking of you know for one
thing the H index which is the H and I
don't know if you know this us but the H
and H index comes from Jorge Hirsch
who's a theoretical physicist at UC San
Diego who has a paper about which
ironically has the most citations I
think of any of his papers
um but this has become you know what
what you know computer geeks call you
know gamification you know I've got this
watch and it tells me how many steps I
took today and if it does if I don't if
I get to 10 000 steps I get some like
animation it feels good
um and of course in science you know the
ultimate you know prize the ultimate
Accolade the ultimate you know
um uh gamified responses to you know
there comes a limit to you can't get
double tenure you can't get you know
multiple uh you know write multiple
papers on the same theme so it becomes
ever escalation from along their
academic rank up the academic rank to
different National academies and then
maybe if you're lucky
um you know Barry barish was here a
couple of months ago he left this here
Martin uh this is his Nobel PR no it's
it's a piece of chocolate uh but um I
want to go and analyze it judge one more
book by its kind cover and that's if
you'll indulge me that's this book
losing the Nobel Prize yes
um which is written by Yours Truly but
it says in the back uh by by you you
were kind enough to give me one of the
first blurbs in this riveting personal
account Brian Keating Rex writes frankly
of the challenges frustrations and
motivations during the years spent
building and operating instruments to
tackle one of the fundamental problems
in science how our universe began and
I'm so grateful for that Martin but
since that time you and I have
communicated many times and and you told
me you love the book but you really wish
I didn't spend so much time on the Nobel
Prize because you were up there and I
quote you in the book and and I think
you know our ideas are in resonance but
um can you explain for the audience why
why you thought that was a mistake
perhaps for me and and I you know I I
I'm no way offended by I I'm eternally
grateful for for your attention and and
kind words and your encomium but um but
why do you think it was a mistake to
maybe focus more on that rather I don't
want to turn this into my favorite
subject which is me but um but why do
you think it was a it was maybe mistaken
to spend you know focus on the Nobel
Prize as itself as they did in three of
the 11 chapters yes
um well I was surprised at your
perception that most scientists are
motivated by that they are in some
Fields I know and uh it's very damaging
it leads to real nastiness in some
competitive Fields
um but to go back to what we were saying
earlier
um science is often um uh assessed by
these uh um indicators like citations
and all that which are perverse uh
indicators because they don't measure
what's really important right um and uh
I I suppose the aim is that these prizes
do
um but um my concern really is about the
public perception of Nobel prizes
um because the public assumes that the
people who win the prizes are all sort
of near Geniuses and they've made some
great individual achievement and and it
uh is misleading in
a number of ways well first any
scientist Builds on the work of others
it's never true to say that a guy who's
caused the goal in football uh did it by
himself he was held by the rest of the
team and that's true of all science and
some science is uh intrinsically
collaborative involving a very large
team of collaborators so that's one
thing but that's not not properly
recommend uh recognized by Annabelle
prizes although it is by some other
prizes have been set up more recently
um so that's one issue um the second
issue is that um people who get Nobel
prizes are
then uh regarded as at least a b-list
celebrities and abuser sought on fields
where they have no expertise and they're
given greater weight uh and uh and this
is um misleading because they don't have
a special Authority and of course one
knows that one can find a Nobel Prize
winner to support almost any kind of
eccentricity so uh so many of them do it
and of course
um some of them are indeed brilliant I'm
in Europe
Stephen Weinberg was obviously put it in
person you know who deserve everything
he got
um but a lot are just lucky like pens
and Wilson
um and uh other people who um get get
the prize for making some discovery
which may be because they had access to
a special piece of equipment or just
Serendipity and so the the
um partier for giving the prize
are to recognize an important advance
and it normally succeeded in doing that
but it doesn't
give the public a feeling for how an
advance is achieved it's not just one
genius working your way at it there are
lots of people in parallel and um I give
um in my section of the book where I
discuss this I have two examples uh
where I I think it it went wrong
uh one was the the Higgs boson which uh
um the the last paper was came from
Higgs but it's accepted that there were
six people who worked on it
independently and they were built on
earlier people like Phil Anderson so a
lot of people are involved um and um
knowing some of these people I think
it's clear that
um uh the person
among those six who had the most
distinguished career overall with some
are called Tom kibble in London
um he was highly respected and he didn't
get the prize right although he had a
far more distinguished overall career
um that's one thing and the other
example is uh uh the case which uh
you're familiar with one of the few
cases where they've given the prize uh
related to the fundamental science
derived from astronomy this was the
evidence of the accelerating universe
and here they gave it to two teams there
were 50 or 15 or 20 people in each team
and they gave it to three people one in
one team two in the other team and I
won't see why they chose those people
they're great guys
um but uh that's the case where it
should have gone to the whole team and
it's misleading to regard those three
people who got the prize as the great
intellects indeed I could identify AI at
least four
people in the teams whose overall record
is more substantial than that of any of
the three people who got the prize
yeah and we've had two of the three
winners have been on the podcast I'm
still waiting for Saul to come on uh uh
hopefully someday that that might happen
but but you know on the other hand to be
Devil's Advocate you know I think
nobel's Advocate uh I I don't think he
ever intended it to to take on the
prominence that it did have and again
we're talking today is the uh the first
of Nobel season which is October 3rd or
the prize uh for medicine or physiology
was awarded to
um svant Pavo I think it's it's too many
umalauts I I can't I can't you know I
can't be expected
yeah so it was it was good and very
distant knowledge of him and hopefully I
can get him on um but but the you know
kind of history of Nobel prizes are a
little bit uh a little bit of rogue's
gallery as you point on not only are
there things uh that are you know
factually incorrect say Bohr's model of
a new mini planetary system for the atom
which had predictive power but
ultimately we know now is not the
correct description of the quantum realm
um but uh or you know some say fermi's
uh Nobel Prize is not quietly rightly
deserved but but speaking of medicine uh
the lobotomy was awarded with the Nobel
Prize and and now that's regarded as
essentially barbaric but even going
further back in time to 1918 the
chemistry prize which you mentioned in
this book was given to uh for Tabor uh
who was a German Jew who ended up making
uh the chemical weapons and overseeing
it with six other Nobel Prize winners
and I have a video about this in my
channel I'll put a link to it called
knowledge is not equal to wisdom because
as it turned out Haber has he went on to
have a factory that went on to produce
zyclon B which was the gas that gased
most of the Jews in the Holocaust
including members of his own family that
perished under
um you know his uh his his inventions
and I wonder mark and we do venerate you
know inventors uh maybe that's you know
partially the the Genesis or or
etymology of that word um that's the Tim
the the Steve Jobs is the you know the
the um even the Alfred nobels and is
that something innate in human beings
that we need like a hero you know we
have sports Heroes we have
um we have uh you know other Heroes on
in theater and in in movies
um what's wrong with having you know a
scientist hero that that people look up
to uh is it or is it putting like just
too much pressure on a single individual
as you say most of these are team
discoveries although Savant today's
winner won it by himself which was kind
of interesting to me but but what do you
make of that that the the ideal you know
to kind of idolize
um it's just runs in human nature and it
will never get around it so maybe we
um you know should just make do with the
Nobel Prize in all its flaws well I mean
I agree with you if they are the people
who really are exceptional I mean uh of
recent ones I would put season 9 bug in
that category for instance and no would
deny it was an exceptional intellect and
and there are quite a few who are like
that
um and Kip Thorne and I put in that
category too
um so quite a number uh but but my
objection is that uh many of them uh
aren't uh in that category at all uh
they're uh no more distinguished in in
general than the average academic in the
university in some cases
um and uh I think many of them realize
this in fact I I remember talking to um
uh a Californian uh uh particle
physicist who got the prize and he said
he said to me I think I'm the dumbest
Nobel Prize winner said and then he went
to say no sorry I correct that I'm the
dumbest physics of a Nobel Prize winner
there were several chemists who are
double
that's right there's uh always room to
to tease chemists as directors want to
do as well yeah
um well I wanna I wanna now turn to an
um to run somebody ideas by you so
you're you're quite
um critical rightfully so uh in many
ways about the the modern Journal
um uh kind of framework where we have
the archive and you talk about Ginsburg
you know Cornell and his monument and
also the Simon's Foundation should be
recognized for their support of it um uh
with they don't get any you know money
in return from it they don't make more
uh you know on their hedge fund uh
profits as far as I know uh but it's
it's basically pure scientific
philanthropy uh and yet we hear things
that you know it's it's not good for
people to say start other types of
prizes like the Breakthrough Prize or
even funding like the Simon's foundation
of the Gordon Moore Foundation and
others where you put so much of
scientific prioritization in the hands
of you know maybe eccentric billionaires
you know it could turn out that they're
collecting you know like Howard Hughes
has one of the most you know you
mentioned in the book how successful
it's been he was pretty eccentric
billionaire I think it's safe to call
him that I don't think it's a spoiler to
anybody so do you worry about that the
prioritization being set by
non-governmental agencies
um no you've completed two or three
different things I wanted to say first
of all I think the the archive is great
yes um and uh I think perhaps the age of
the journal
um is coming to a close
um we need some kind of quality control
um but that could come from the archive
especially if we introduce something new
like for instance the restaurant critics
who can give a star to a papers they
like
um and uh if if your paper on the
archive gets Stars which was not be
anonymous they must be signed by the
person given if the stars are from
people who are respected in the field
right then that's to the genuine craze
of the paper and uh young people who
can't read all the literature will then
tend to read papers which have got stars
from reputable people and so that's that
will be a way of bypassing uh the
refereeing and I think
um uh roughing actually it's a worse
problem in the humanities and in
economics that is in science because in
the in economics there are a few
journals
which uh allegedly caregrated Prestige
and a would-be academic has to get at
least one paper in one of those journals
I think we're not quite in that state in
in our sciences no I think the the
archive is is is great
um and I think also young academics
should in perotion criteria uh be able
to include not just the papers they've
written but good blogs they've written
and public lectures and all these things
and YouTube channels yeah maybe yes I
think all those things There's Hope for
me to win the YouTube the other question
you asked was about the uh the role of
private sponsorship and um uh I think
this is welcome I mean the problems may
arise if the uh donor
wants to control uh the um framework and
of course most academic organizations
um have criteria where they would not
allow that to happen that uh if if
someone endows as a chair they normally
aren't allowed to be on their point of
committee for the chair for instance and
so as long as those rules are followed
then I think once you're hugely welcome
this and um uh the assignments is
probably the biggest foundation in the
physical sciences and there are others
and there's an outfit called the
philanthropic Alliance which was set up
a few years ago with the aim of
encouraging wealthy people to consider
um donations to uh physical sciences of
course astronomy has had a head start
because I think if you look back to the
U.S
who built your telescopes it was mainly
private sponsors so I think you can look
back to this guy we can look back to
Galileo you know build telescopes but
his discoveries were named after his
patrons right yes yes but but I think um
uh astronomy has been more favored than
any other physical sciences did any
other non-medical Sciences in terms of
private sponsorship
um but I think it's very good that uh
there should be private sponsorship to
give a diversity of support and I think
it's especially important given that um
the pressure on um in your country the
NSF in my country ukri is getting
greater and um rather vexatious in the
number of forms you have to fill in to
to get a grant and then to process the
grant when you got it so I think it's
very good that there are these varied
sources of support
yeah and then there are things like the
institute for advanced study uh on which
you've served as a trustee
um uh just to Pivot back I'm sorry it's
it's it's you know it's always a wild
ride when you're when you're talking to
a to a a New Yorker like myself but um
but going back to the journals uh I
wondered if I could maybe uh you and I
could could flesh out some possible
Alternatives because you know it's it's
not good and you never do this you never
just criticize you always have solutions
that you talk about one solution that's
getting a lot of attention and
especially on as you know from being a
guest on Lex Friedman's podcast
um we won't talk about aliens uh don't
worry uh almost every uh podcast he does
involves aliens but another major
subject is is blockchain or you know
Bitcoin technology and I've been
thinking a little bit about that and how
we could use the blockchain type
technology to not circumvent journals
but there are legitimate cases in the
bicep Affair that I write about in the
book you co so kindly burped uh we had
this you know debate on the team like
can we submit it to Nature you know and
or you know and in the end we end up
submitting a 25 Page Long paper to Fizz
rev letters uh which is the longest in
history and they've never repeated that
sense and maybe that's a good thing but
you know for nature they wanted all
these embargoes that we couldn't release
the day we couldn't have a press
conference until uh until it was
accepted for publication so they did
read it and I believe those I wasn't in
the senior leadership by this moment so
I may get the details wrong but um but
that was part of the reason we didn't
want to embargo it we want to get it out
as soon as possible such that a referee
might not want to be able to scoop us
with the advanced knowledge of of you
know what our results were because they
were so dramatically above the
expectation of everybody including you
would have predicted for the tensor to
scalar ratio
um so it was a Consciousness now what if
you had a blockchain and encoded when it
was like you know what Leonardo or
Galileo used to do when he discovered
what he thought were three moons around
Saturn uh he said the the highest planet
is three-fold there or something and has
ears
it wrote cryptically and Leonardo wrote
In The Mirror what if you could encrypt
things in the blockchain so that you
know bicep has discovered that the the
primordial it could be really poetic it
could be really cool you know the the
reverberations are the 20 of the me you
know whatever I don't know we could make
a joke about it but but in all
seriousness could you envision some way
of establishing priority which is like
it or not important for scientists
um sometimes generated by things that
aren't so important like winning the
prize but but nevertheless priority is
important for careers and such
um so what could we do um to circumvent
this ossified you know 100 how old is
nature you know for example at 160 years
old or something
um it's pretty much unchanged just like
much of Academia so I want to ask you
could we could you envision a state
where you could encode you know maybe
even clinical trials or things that
would be open source uh but it would
also establish reproduce disability but
it would also establish priority is
there any hope for that well I mean I'm
not sure how after the power is
important I mean it's only important if
you're in the field where
the thought is frustrating that you're
only making Discovery a month before
someone else would do it I mean it's
much better to be in the field where uh
you feel you're making a distinctive
difference and no one else is competing
with you so I think people should stay
away from the fields where they have to
worry about by someone a month later
well I'm sorry Martin I have to push
back with respect in this book you talk
about the difference between science and
art and you say something like if
Botticelli never made whatever he made
uh then no one would have made it but if
Einstein didn't have his anus mirabales
someone else would have done it maybe it
would have been later maybe it would
have been mikowski and you know who
knows but what do you make of that uh I
mean there is a priority there's a rush
in science and some competitors they
will do it later but to take the case of
Einstein if he hadn't existed then his
work would have been done over the next
decade or two published by several
different people not one single great
mind yes um but I I think um
it would be okay I just wanted in most
cases I mean for instance bicep that was
a unique facility no one else was going
to be able to do do that and scoop and
scoop you
um and and so you could have published
the paper
um and well it's it's
um just again to just uh in terms of the
actual event so we had we had been
worried that the Planck satellite
actually could have seen it actually
George of statio who you know
undoubtedly very well at your
institution yeah um who's coming to I'm
going to meet with him hopefully in New
York in a couple months uh he's he's uh
our renowned scientist he had written a
paper not too long before a few years
before that said that they had the
capability to measure the same signal as
us but at higher statistical
significance so we and they wouldn't
share their data with us on the
foreground so it started to make us
think well maybe they know something and
um but but anyway I interrupted I'm
sorry but uh yeah but I don't think it's
strictly true that nobody could have if
it were really as high as 20 percent of
the scalar contributions they would have
seen it
yes um but but the other the other point
I was going to make is this um uh
refereeing is only important for a uh a
long difficult looking paper which uh
students might waste a lot of time
reading no proof wrong um any high
profile paper
um will get far more discussion
um on the web or coffee timing
institutions
the day it appeared on the archive I
mean I think that's true of any exciting
papers appears on the archive
um the uh um the intensity of the
criticism it gets within a day or two
from all the people read it and discuss
it
um at the water cooler or coffee and all
that is going to be greater so the
refereeing is not important and and I
think um that has had the results I
think that's in many cases
um the paper on the on the archive has
been modified
um when it's in his final form uh but
not by referees but by General input and
the view that some particular aspect of
it was a bit dubious and so uh I think
it's only four papers which are not
going to attract much attention that
refereeing is essential to keep
standards up if that's important then
everyone's going to read it and comment
on it
yes very good
um so I want to turn now to well first
of all I want to uh remind people as my
podcast obligation
as has uh spelled out in the Geneva
Convention I must remind people every
hour who we're speaking to and it's such
a treat to speak with a hero uh and a
great friend uh as I say University of
California San Diego uh UC system uh and
uh and all of science as as well as uh
personal hero to Yours Truly and that's
Lord Martin Reese the astronomer Royal
uh author of many many books uh I first
got introduced to you in the in the 90s
Martin
um and your wonderful book uh just six
numbers really revolutionary winner of
the Templeton prize
um along with uh uh Freeman Dyson who is
our first guest on the podcast I don't
know if you knew that uh Lord and Martin
that Freeman was my first guest and you
quote him in your wonderful annual
reviews of astronomy and astrophysics
you said when I received the Templeton
prize he told me that made him feel
better about having one in himself as I
just done as little to deserve it as he
had of course you add I've done far less
now Freeman was a wonderful a wonderful
man and and
um and really a great friend I remember
introducing him to my
um my he must have been five-year-old
and and Freeman was born exactly 90
years almost to the day uh before my
four-year-old so they were like you know
talking about but he could talk about
anything it was uh it was he's such a
he's such a Titanic mind and I I miss
him uh terribly he's been gone a few
years now
um but you know one of the things that
he and I used to talk about on the
couple of episodes that he honored me
with is the difference between you know
Mysteries and puzzles a mystery being uh
something that is uh that is perhaps in
inscrutable that you cannot understand
and a puzzle which is something that you
might not I mean I'm not talking about
you but I might not be able to solve a
crossword puzzle in the Sunday Times but
my mother can or you know my kid can
solve a Rubik's Cube but I can't really
do that
um so they're soluble but not maybe by
you but Mysteries are perhaps forever
inscrutable according to Freeman and I
kind of added on my own little twitch
twist to that was that like the meaning
of life as a scientist was to convert as
many Mysteries as possible into puzzles
uh because you know we like to solve
things and and I wonder Martin if you
could think about the most mysterious
thing that remains in science and the
greatest puzzle you've solved so many
puzzles Martin
um it's really just like you're like
they used to say about Stephen Hawking
they thought he was borbachi you know a
collective but you've done so many
things what's your favorite puzzle and
what's your favorite mystery that still
lingers perhaps forever
well I think I'll get the same answer
probably most classmologists would give
which is that
um we can trace back with confidence to
win the universe has been expanding for
just uh microseconds because after the
first microsecond the physics
is is known but in the first microsecond
particles are moving around with energy
is how they can readily achieve in
accelerators but many of the key
features of the universe as we all
accept were laid down at a far far
earlier stage still to put in
perspective
um when the universe was
a microsecond old
the observable universe was about the
size of the solar system whereas when
all the action happened the universe was
the size of a tennis ball and then
expanded for something microscopic and
so that's a huge jump from the physics
we understand and uh this is
um a challenge and I think the question
is will this be forever a mystery or
will we be able to
um understand this physics because
obviously people are working on string
theory and all the rest of it and let's
hope that we can uh probe one stage
deeper because it's amazing that in the
50 years when I've been active in
science you've gone from not knowing
whether there was a big bang at all uh
to knowing in quite a lot of detail uh
how it evolved right back from a
microsecond to the present
um but but I think the fundamental laws
of nature
um
which may be represented by String
Theory or maybe something quite
different it's possible that they could
be beyond the capacity of human brains
quite possible
um and of course one can then ask would
AI be able to to solve them and and this
is I think a possible scenario it could
be that the the maths of the
10-dimensional spaces and geometry is
too hard for a human to work through but
some kind of maybe not present but
future AI could work through it all and
if the AI after chucking away uh came
out at the end with the correct mass of
the electron or some correct numbers for
the
now on known parameters of the standard
model then we'd know it was on the right
track and we'd never though get the real
insight which is the main satisfaction
of science when in retrospect something
looks obvious to you this would never
look obvious to you but this might be
the only way we would understand these
but there might be as I say aspects of
physical reality which um are Beyond us
uh just as quantum theory is beyond a
monkey
yeah that's a possibility yeah go ahead
but we've then got to realize that one
thing we learned as astronomers
um and this is one I think particular
attitude that astronomers can bring to
uh public discourse in general is that
the future
is as long as the past I mean most
people are aware that we're the outcome
of nearly four billion years of
biological evolution but many tend to
feel that we're the top of the tree we
have these combinations of this whereas
of course we know in astronomy that the
sun's less than halfway through its life
and the universe will go on for much
much much longer and so um we are aware
that the all kinds of emergent
properties which will make the future
far more amazing than the present
yeah and I wonder you mentioned uh
artificial intelligence and I can't uh
resist running you know this analogy by
you which is um this this gentleman who
you mentioned a couple minutes back
Albert Einstein uh do you recall what he
called his happiest thought Martin
um
it was the the elevator yes yes it was
that yeah
he would experience no gravitational for
it so I want to ask you to what extent
could AI Einstein a i a e could it them
Z experience a a happiest thought and B
a sensation that's anthropomorphic of
falling in other words do we have
anything to worry about I mean the
Primitive nature of AI at this point
seems you know painfully obvious I mean
Elon Musk who you always lovingly refer
to as you know wanting to die on Mars
but you hope that he doesn't die on
impact I love that line I always
attribute it to you uh but you know Elon
revealed these AI Bots that can lift up
packages and it's great and it's
wonderful they're doing trillions of
computations per second but is that The
Ghost and the Machine
um or is your you know rival uh rival
University Oxford uh and oxonian Sir
Roger Penrose has been a guest many
times on the show uh really think that
the brain isn't a computer at all um
where do you fall in that kind of
dichotomy
this is a brand a computer or no one
comments on Roger penrose's ideology is
amazing the stage 91. yeah personally
have his ideas as ever he's a really
good great guy
um but but I think um I'd answer two
ways I mean I think it's clear that um
AI
um uh does have superhuman powers to do
restricted things playing Go and all
that
um but that's very different as you're
saying uh from uh general intelligence
and so I think
um in order to uh
have the sort of General intenses it's
got to actually interact with the
external world
because uh you know we we've heard
recently about uh these um AIS that can
digest billions of pages of prints and
they can write what looked like serious
sensible paragraphs Etc but they don't
have any uh concept of the things that
those words denote they just know which
words are tied together in particular
ways and that's why they can write
sensible sentences so I think it's a
it's going to be a long time before
machines can interact with the external
World directly hmm
if they were to discover new laws of
nature that would be necessary I think
to interact external World
um but even if they they can do that
then of course
um there's the fundamental problem of
philosophers uh um whether uh
capability implies self-awareness and
Consciousness
um and uh and that's an open question
Prince philosopher Berkeley cell of
course would have argued it didn't and
so it's I think still an open question
whether the uh AI even if it has
superhuman capabilities in many
directions whether it's got
self-awareness
right able to uh have emotions as it
were we just don't know yeah I see it
very reminiscent of sort of the Drake
equation uh where we kind of post you
know put these uh posteriori
expectations of what an AI or an alien
you know would look like or do and I
really have no idea whatsoever
yeah so I proposed that Drake I told
Nick Bostrom over there at Oxford yeah
he's come up with Bostrom equation and
and uh he's pretty dismissed he doesn't
like the Drake equation and um yeah no
disrespect to the late great Frank Drake
my take which is discussed in another
book
um that um I think the Drake equation is
rather misleading because if we think of
what's happened on the Earth
it's taken four billion years and we've
got a technological civilization of
Flesh and Blood creatures but in the
four billion years ahead then maybe we
will be usurped by electronic entities
right that they'd be near Immortal and
they won't uh unless you want to stay on
the planet at all and so they they won't
be deterred by the set of voyages and so
um if we imagine that there was another
Earth
uh where life had evolved as on the
earth then only if it was very very
closely synchronized would we observe it
during this interval of just a few
centuries when he's got a technological
Flesh and Blood civilization I little be
well behind us in this case we see no
evidence of intelligence ought to be
well ahead in which case what we will
see will detect will be the electronic
remote progeny of That civilization and
uh this is um I think a very serious
let's say modification of the Drake
equation because
um the the progeny may exist for
billions of years
um even if the uh civilization
In the Flesh and Blood sense only lasts
for thousands of years uh so I I I'm
optimistic about seti detecting some
kind of artifacts but if it does then I
think they're more likely to be uh
electronic artifacts left by some long
dead civilization
oh that's great to hear that fully
fleshed out
um I wonder if we could go and uh you
know remaining time that we have to some
of the details of the book although I
have to say I always hated it when I'd
go on a conversation and someone said
you know can you summarize the book
entirely so that I don't have to read it
and my audience doesn't have to buy no I
want you to buy this book in as many
formats as possible because it is it's a
slim easy read I actually had it read to
me as I explained to Lord Martin by none
other than Gwyneth Paltrow by taking a a
PDF converting it to speechify and
selecting her premium voice and it is uh
as as lugubrious as you would expect uh
it's it's blurbed on the back by uh past
guest on the podcast my podcast Stephen
Pinker the author of rationality at
Harvard University with whom Lord Martin
has collaborated on several uh on
several articles uh Stephen called it a
judicious And Timely presentation of
nothing less than how to save the world
for from one of our wisest scientists
and public voices and I should say that
Martin
is available uh 24 7 if you like if you
go to thetwitter.com website where he is
Lord Martin and you can get all his uh
hot takes on Manchester United on Adele
no no you can't get that but you'll get
uh his greatest uh thoughts that fit
into 280 characters and I wonder Martin
uh speaking of Twitter which you joined
a few years ago
um and uh and I I delightfully follow
you
um I want to I want to kind of think as
a practicing scientist and and go back
uh even further you know than than the
names we've mentioned so far and go back
to to
um Sean Clerk Maxwell uh James Clark
Maxwell rather uh Scotsman and and his
theory of electromagnetism and his
famous eponymous four equations of
electromagnetism which uh are
undoubtedly true and tested you know
perhaps as as good as human beings will
ever be able to test and prove and
verify and hold across the cosmos but
but um but Maxwell was troubled uh
wasn't he by the fact that he didn't see
a mechanism by which these waves could
be transmitted and so he proposed that
there were a series of vortices and
gears and and all sorts of you know
strange phenomena that we know don't
exist uh later would be kind of deemed
The Ether and that that would later be
rejected in the Michelson Morley
experiment Center
um can you imagine uh you know James
Clerk Maxwell on Twitter so he comes up
with these ideas and these equations and
then and then velocity goes through is
well this is instantiated by these gears
and and flexions and and [ __ ] you know
virtuous luminiferous ether
um he'd be a laughingstock right that's
crazy you know hurts would prove him
wrong a couple but would we throw the
baby out with the bath water and I guess
I'm wondering nowadays
um there are voices that are not in the
majority these are people that don't
believe uh necessarily in a quantum
singularity and origin of the universe
these aren't crackpots these are you
know Friends of the show like Paul
steinhardt and Aegis Neil Turok who is
just on this past week um the Higgs
professor at uh at James clerk Maxwell's
alma mater right uh at the University of
Edinburgh
um I said Edinburgh on my inner I was so
embarrassed Martin but but anyway
um well imagine are we stifling voices
by this kind of instantaneous need to to
you know put things on Twitter and and
have gotcha moments and and you don't
engage in it I'm not implying at all
that that's your Twitter account's Focus
right but
um are we perhaps stifling you know by
the thought of public embarrassment
maybe some really good ideas like Paul
is not on you know Neil is not on uh on
Twitter et cetera et cetera and I wonder
if that's a good thing or a bad thing
has has Twitter been a net positive for
science not just for you know getting
the hottest takes in the royal family
and what Kate Middleton is doing today
what do you think is the benefit and and
maybe pitfalls of Twitter social media
in general
well I mean I don't think Twitter's very
important in science I mean I think uh
certain blogs are important
um and uh uh and should be encouraged um
but I think on the question you ask
about uh uh you know minority views
um I think it's very indeed very
important to encourage them and they're
uh that's why um I do hope that
um uh despite what I've said about
science becoming unattractive as a
career because it's an overcoming
universities I hope some of those who
don't do science and go and work in a
startup will make enough money to become
independent scientists I mean in the
19th century there were independent
scientists like uh uh Darwin and
Rayleigh but they were independently
wealthy but there can be people now uh
who um make enough money by the time
they're 40 and they can become
independent scientists not to be good
because that will provide a greater
diversity of opinion there's a risk of
group think obviously in the universes
and of course there's a clustering
tendency because if we think about
um
speculative theories like string theory
Etc then as you know the Rival theories
loophant of gravity and others and one
of the problems is that if you're a
career academic
then you want to write papers that quite
a lot of people will read and that
therefore means as a clustering tendency
you tend to focus on what already the uh
um the most heavily studied option
whereas in fact we want the reverse to
happen we want people to uh spread out
their efforts
um and uh the trouble is that the uh the
risk to get a lot of readers is contrary
to to that it's pressing the wrong way
right and and yeah I mean it's one of
these things that I mean interestingly
enough it does have some you know
geopolitical I mean today Elon you're
you're one of your frequent subjects of
uh of amusement it was tweeting about
you know here's how can we uh do you
agree this is how the Ukraine war should
end and you know annexation of Crimea
should be ratified and this and uh I was
a vote on it and he's like you have to
vote again and and make sure you vote uh
and like at some level I'm sure
somebody's listening to what he says I
mean he's an awfully influential person
yes
um so another theme in this book and
it's been a constant theme with many of
your fellow countrymen uh and and that
is uh folks like Tim Palmer who's uh got
a new book coming out and was on the
show a couple of weeks ago uh that video
should be out by the time this video is
out uh and uh and also I had on
um uh I had on Neil Ferguson uh who is a
Scotsman I guess I don't know you can
consider Scotsman part of the UK I don't
know I don't know how any of that works
so it's more complicated than CMB
cosmology which we'll get to as well as
audience questions so I'll send my
audience asks you some questions we're
going to get to those at the very end in
the next few minutes we're going to wrap
up so you can have a good supper and
proper supper indeed
um but
okay uh so Neil uh and Tim and now you
have um have discussed the the kind of
intermeshing of two vast forces which
one of which you might not have written
about had this book come out three years
and five days ago or something and
that's covid-19 and uh also uh global
warming which obviously has been around
for a very long time
um when I talk with with both of them
they they uh Tim and Neil uh discussed
and it's not the Neil Ferguson that I
think at Imperial who came up with this
drastic forecast uh which uh which
didn't thankfully turn out to be true
for UK deaths but anyway it's the other
one the the Scottish historian and so
forth that the Hoover institution in
America anyway uh the two of them
um write that these are intertwined in
some way and perhaps by the efficacy of
the Global Response or inefficacy
um and perhaps by you know one of the
few things that can unite a planet
perhaps but but uh it doesn't seem to be
too successful in in that
um I want to I want to take take myself
back and my listeners back
um to January of 2020 I was at a Shabbat
dinner a Friday night dinner with some
friends and one of my friends told me uh
because I told him I'm going to visit
the CMB observatory in uh in Tibet that
the Chinese are building and they want
me to to see it and give it to her and
so forth and I was excited I'd never
been to Tibet or China at all uh so I
was happily going to do this and in
January of 2020 my friend said well you
better postpone it when is it going to
be and I said April and he said oh no
you better postpone until like July
because there's a thing called covid-19
and they're dealing with it and and he
was joking yeah they welded about 10 000
people inside of a hospital prison and
oh that's kind of weird but I'm not
going to be in Beijing so I don't care
I'll just be in this nice safe place
called Tibet and he's like yeah you
should still think about it um and yet
Martin here in America you know if my
friend you know some you know uh and me
a yenta at a dinner party in January
knew enough to know that there was this
Global Response and the P or at least in
China there was this drastic response
and people were taking incredible you
know precautions and so forth
um you would think that the
multi-trillion dollar three-letter
agencies here
um and in their you know I mean we have
NSA DARPA doe NSF all these agencies
blew it and and they're scientists right
so they didn't save us and and there you
have what MI6 as I understand you know
James no I I don't I don't mean to imply
that but but other institutions science
funding institutions
did anyone get it right a and how can we
save face after you know saying well we
kind of blew it on covet 19. science
included but certainly the military and
these huge budgets but but trust is on
global warming we got it this time you
know we our models are forecast our
computer simulations they didn't work so
well for for this uh pandemic but
they're going to work much better 50 to
100 years from now with global warming
what do you say to such a uh could I
think I think what you said about uh uh
the attitude to covid-19 is very unfair
I mean it's true that uh uh the uh
lockdowns and things were perhaps uh
instigated too late but I would say it
showed science is best because uh the uh
scientific experts out in the UK they're
on television every day with the Prime
Minister uh giving their views and
they're respected
um and the uh scientific effort was
International and the uh vaccine project
was amazing successful when we don't
have a vaccine for uh HIV after 40 years
so I would say it was a great
achievement and the public got a sort of
Education in science because early on
the um way the disease was transmitter
was unclear there was a lot of debate
about whether wearing masks was
important or waste of time Etc and these
things get gradually firmed up and the
public could watch this happening so I
would say this was a case when
scientists were listened to because they
did deliver and there was urgency I
think if you take global warming which
is in a sense a slow-motion version of a
catastrophe then the point is that um uh
the worst of it is far beyond the
horizons the time Horizons of
politicians and of course in part of the
world they far away from the UK and the
US
um and so that that's why action is um
very hard to uh Implement and to get
public support for and I think in the
case of uh climate change
um I think there's now a consensus about
the science
um but I think the question of what to
do about it now urgent it is to respond
and about litigation and adaptation uh
that's a matter for proper debates um
but I think um the main thing that's
lacking is um political willingness to
act and that's because
um politics will only
do something if they think voters care
they won't lose votes by it and so
that's why it's so important that
scientists should explain the issues to
a wide public and they should be um
aimed by aided by uh charismatic
individuals who can do a better job as
influencers massage themselves can I
mean it's very sad that Carl Sagan isn't
still alive because he would be
obviously uh leading a campaign to his
eloquence
um that will make people take uh global
warming and loss of diversity seriously
but I mean I I mentioned in my book for
sort of charismatic figures very
different from each other who have had
quite a big effect uh one is Pope
Francis who is encyclical in uh 2015
which led to the standing invasion of
the UN and the consensus at the 2015
climate conference second David
Attenborough I was made aware of
biodiversity and uh the problem of
plastic in the ocean and climate change
so third is Bill Gates who talks in a
great deal of sense in his books about
how we can deal with climate change and
for fourth greater Thornburg who uh has
been the spokesperson for the younger
generation uh who are still going to be
alive at the end of a century and
naturally care more about this so people
like that have I think raised public
interest and awareness
and that's meant that voters will
support this action
um and uh we need well more people like
that and to change the rhetoric
of business even although business has
not responded enough so I'm hopeful that
the awareness of this General but
long-term threat will deepen and widen
and that then the politicians will start
to take action
very good
um and in the closing moments that we
have I can't resist but be a little bit
selfish and and pivot back to where as I
said I met you way back when uh which
was CME polarization in the 19 late
1960s just about three years after the
discovery of the uh background glow the
cosmic microwave background that pays
the bills around the Keating house
um you were very present you predicted
the uh possibility of a polarization
signal can you explain what led you to
that uh again this is a very nascent
field it would be like you know somebody
really going all in on uh you know Dark
Energy uh you know research in the early
2000s say when it was just becoming
clear that Serendipity struck then and
struck back in the 60s what gave you the
confidence to go into the impossible as
this podcast is titled
um to to pursue that field as a young
scientists starting out
well I mean at at this time uh
everyone's worried about why the
universe was homogeneous it was before
the idea of inflation which uh may be
the answer to that but this didn't
happen and there's a popular idea due
particularly so the guy called uh Mizner
which is that um the universe went
through a so-called Mix Master phase
where it expanded fast in One Direction
and then fast another and he was able to
show that causal contact in that
Universe was better and so you could
understand why the universe homogenized
early on and uh which is was a big
mystery in otherwise and so um this was
the idea of universe Rivers homogeneous
but anisotropic it expanded fast in One
Direction then another and then I I
realized that in those models uh we
would expect polarization
um because the polarization will depend
on where the expansion was fastest and
slowest at the time of recombination uh
so I was focusing on that but then I did
mention at the end uh that uh
polarization would be a natural outcome
of of any case when you had the um the
gas moving around relative to the
radiation
um so so that that was I think the first
paper written on CMP polarization yes
absolutely and in the book you talk or
in the in the book you do talk about
obligations you know one of my favorite
uh passages you're really kind of
debating or discussing
um the roles and basically the
trade-offs between human Ingenuity I.E
technology and and basically whatever
the opposite is uh uh which is which is
adaptation and you know I I wonder if
you could look into your Crystal I have
a crystal ball somewhere around here but
but if you can look into the crystal
ball and and think about the trend
Transformations that could attack both
the covid-19 and global warming from the
perspective of an astronomer you ask a
question you know what does an
astronomer have to Alpine on this and
then you answer in the affirmative they
have a lot to say I wonder let's let's
talk about first uh covet 19. so you
mentioned these vaccines and it is true
they have properties of you know uh that
that do inhibit the spread of disease
and they're very positive beneficial but
they're you know in terms of efficacy
and so forth against a uh an adversary
if you will that has seven billion 900
million petri dishes at any moment to be
experimenting on
um you know what what hope can physics
or maybe astronomy you know is too too
narrow but can physics address there I
mean crispr played a role in it you talk
about crispr in the book talk about
Jennifer doudna et cetera but um but you
don't really maybe get into the
molecular biology of it are there is
there a hope to save us from physics
necessarily or is it sort of out of the
realm of where you know you or I as
astronomers might be properly situated
in our own Lanes
um Can physics maybe help save us from
future pandemics if you had a bet now
based on what we've experienced recently
I don't but there's one point I often
emphasize is that physics is the easy
subject biologists are hard subjects
that's right you talk about the ease of
detecting black holes
the virus or a small organism are far
greater than anything in the cosmos so
it's a biological subject so I'm
hesitate to comment but I think you know
I I do worry because it's too we uh we
can hope that vaccine technology will
improve but on the other hand
um uh in a more crowded world uh new
variants are going to appear all the
time and uh my greatest nightmare is of
course engineered viruses
um which could be used by uh Bad actors
as it were to create endemics so I do
worry very much about whether the world
can be freed from in fact ever more
serious pandemic so that's a big worry
uh in the quite separate issue of
climate change then of course um uh this
this uh involves physics
um the modeling of climate change
involves physics I mean Fritz is quite
interesting things like cloud formation
which depends on The Eccentric droplets
super cool before they crystallize and
things like that
um that probably Ken Palmer discussed
this sort of thing which you think how
cloud cover changes in a warming World
um so we can hope for better physics and
larger computers which can allow us to
do better predictions of uh of climate
on a regional basis
um but of course what we want to do is
to have ways of producing energy and
storing energy without using fossil
fuels and here again
um scientific and advances mainly from
physics are going to be crucial you know
better battery technologies
um Etc and more efficient solar panels
all these things
um that they're going to be needed so I
think uh climate change is a problem for
physicists
and of course I include Engineers
because the other point I make in the
book is that the amount of brain power
needed in the application of science is
greater than that needed in doing pure
signs so uh we need some clever new
ideas but then we hope they have to be
applied by Engineers to be uh cost
effective and the key thing is to enable
us to provide
um uh clean energy and therefore Net
Zero
um
not just for ourselves
in a Northern rich countries but to
enable the global South
to do the same because they if they uh
can't use cleaners you can't afford it
then they will be four billion people
and as they develop they will use
a lot of fossil fuels and they will
produce about 40 as much CO2 per year as
we now do to be far from Net Zero so
it's very important to ensure that the
global South can LeapFrog directly to
clean energy just as they LeapFrog
directly to uh smartphones and never had
landlines yeah and I wonder so we in the
north have to uh have a fast development
program not just for our own sake but in
order to collaborate with them yeah Tim
suggests that CERN
analog for climate change application
supercomputing we're not we're not
nearly using the full spectrum of super
Computing resources but I was even
thinking as an astrophysicist
relativistic astrophysicist who's worked
on so many fundamental topics as we
mentioned uh CMB uh polarization and
isotropy also black holes compact
objects uh I wonder if not you know an
astronomer who else because we are the
kind of purveyors of fusion and really
figured out Fusion quite long ago and I
wonder to what extent could we have a
great deal of hope to be saved not from
just you know solar powered you know
windmills but from from Fusion uh from
actual low-cost you know if in other
words if God or you know Mother Earth or
somebody tells you Hensley Martin here's
a here's a working you know net positive
and you talk about itar and other things
here and um and the triple the triple uh
parameter but um what if you were handed
here's a design here's this uh for
Fusion where would that and it's and it
would be effective in net net positive
what would be its role and maybe to some
extent fission's role in the portfolio
to tackle
um to tackle uh these global warming
challenges because you know to push back
again with respect you know Greta
thunberg you know she's a vocal opponent
of the cleanest most reliable you know
alternative green energy and she's a
dramatic opponent of fission reactors
and I find that ultimately
and conceivable that she would be
against the only source that we know
because of you know the the nuclear
waste problem and maybe some terrorist
concerns and stuff which are legitimate
but not to the level of if we really
think the world is coming to an end
metaphorically speaking for humans in
our current style the world's going to
be fine right Martin the the planet's
going to go on without us it'll be it'll
be here but for our children our
children's children what would be the
role of fission and fusion in the
portfolio if you were Lord of Earth
Barton race not just uh of the British
Empire
well I mean I think as you know
um the whether we need nuclear this is
something which is controversial yes at
all levels of expertise someday people
have strong views but even experts have
strong views and uh um a great return
could probably find half the experts in
the world who would say that we can get
by
um with uh effective storage not just
for overnight but for six months
um and if that can be done then and with
um solar energy
Etc maybe EXO lenses with space as well
as on the ground uh maybe that could be
done so it's not clear that uh nuclear
energy is is needed
um on the other hand other people say we
should at least uh do r d into fourth
generation nuclear fission
um I tend to be on the latter side but I
think
um it's uh it's not obvious that that's
ever going to work so I think you've got
to be a bit fairer at the greater term
but lots of people would share the view
that we can get to Net Zero without
nuclear
um that's one thing but what what about
uh uh Fusion yeah um there again
um well everyone knows that that's more
distant
um and uh it's probably feasible you
know the problems you've got to
um stabilize the magnetic field for long
enough and all that and I think this
could be done but whether it'll be
economic
um I don't know but uh uh there again
I'm very much in favor of the are indeed
into into fusion and it's very good that
there are now about 20 20 separate
groups around the world
um doing different designs
um and uh iter as you mentioned uh in
retrospect that's that's too big
um because they didn't think they could
get a magnetic fields stronger than one
Tesla I think when they when they built
it and if you can have stronger Fields
then you can get by with smaller scale
and that's been done by by the later
developments so as I think that's true
uh of course there's a quite different
um kind of uh Fusion using
um lasers focusing on little pellets
yeah um I must say I I've uh I tend to
be skeptical about that it seems very
hard to scale up and I'm afraid I've
regarded that as a sort of fig Leaf to
justify the nuclear research they're
doing at Livermore
yeah the Nova uh laser
um so I I won't speak negatively about a
fellow University of California no I'm
just kidding I would if I knew more
about it but they recently did report
net positive or exothermic yeah that's
right although that's controversial some
experts like past guest on the show
Charles seif at NYU suggests that's kind
of moving the goal post you know
painting the Target around the arrow
um so Lord Martin I want to finish up by
asking a few uh questions from my
audience and then I'm going to conclude
with my patented Fantastic Four frilling
for final questions that I ask all my
guests when they honor me as you have by
coming on the show this being your
second appearance on the show so the
first question uh comes from a listener
uh on YouTube and by the way you can ask
me any questions at uh Dr Brian Keating
on YouTube and Dr Brian Keating on
Twitter and you can ask Dr uh Martin
Reese Lord Martin Reese at Lord
martinreys on Twitter he may or may not
respond uh with emojicons the way that I
will but the first
uh question comes from a listener uh
named Huxley underscore s uh who opines
he or she says I think trust in science
is at an all-time low Lord Martin is it
possible to reverse this and how
um well I question that statement I
would have thought that uh the response
to the pandemic uh certainly increase
The Prestige of science it's not high
enough uh but I think the fact that the
vaccines were produced within a year my
groups that was certainly an amazing
scientific achievement and I think um uh
if you certainly compare the trust in
science with the trust in the
politicians journalists uh bankers and
others athletes
and so I I I don't share the pessimist
we've got to improve and we've got to
interact with the public better but I
think science
although some people are concerned about
its scary downsides uh does have a
positive image
so great thank you
um next uh King Posse asks uh but where
the danger is also grows the saving
power that's a quote from Friedrich
holderlin Patmos and the question that
King Posse one asks is does sir Martin
believe there's such thing as a saving
power
maybe a supernatural one and if yes Lord
Martin what form does it take or can it
be physically observed
what I'm saying to you
um
well I mean I don't I don't believe
um in any sort of uh saving part of that
kind I think uh we humans have to avoid
destroying ourselves and apply our
growing knowledge uh to human benefit
and it's clear that this is possible we
can even with present knowledge make a
world for the entire population which is
as good as the world we enjoy in
countries like the United States and the
UK so we can do this
um and I think we we have I mean um uh I
don't think we're going to get any uh
help from outside
um our own human efforts
very good so the next one is coming from
a a listener viewer on YouTube
um who goes by a name that I almost
chose for one of my children and that is
zero skull uh zero skull asks
um a very long question so Pro tip for
my listeners out there if you want to uh
have a high shot at asking your question
me asking it make it short uh because I
can't read this whole thing but he says
what exactly is meant by save us and
save the world save us in what way save
us from who save us for what reasoned
purpose why not just ride it to the end
and counter to frost go gently into the
good night so what do we save from by
science
well I think most of us do care about
the uh survivor of the human species and
uh my concern is that for the first time
in this Century there are realistic
scenarios whereby the misuse of science
could lead to a collapse of civilization
and we certainly have a bumpy ride
through the century because of the
misuse of Science by Bad actors so I
think we are going through a difficult
century and um uh being a human being
myself I certainly feel that our species
deserves to survive and to do better in
future centuries but more than that I
think we should value the um the entire
biological
um
environment that we are in and avoid
mass extinctions and we are risking
those and I quote in my book The Great
ecologist here Wilson who says if human
actions cause mass extinctions it's the
sin that future Generations will least
forgive us for right they want to make
sure that there are future generations
and that they uh are forgiving because
we have helped not ourselves to survive
only but also the natural world to
survive
very very good well uh Lord Martin this
has been a tremendous honor as usual for
me I now want to conclude with what I
call the Fantastic Four but seeing as
you've been on before when it was the
thrilling three I'm just going to ask
you the new aspects of this question
that are pertinent to this new book and
uh and they are as follows so
new quote in this book uh a quote from
the namesake of the Arthur C Clarke
Center for human imagination you say any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic that's one
of his famous quotes and it's
um led me to kind of ask people if you
could hit one discovery not necessarily
by you although it's it's totally
acceptable if you made the discovery
um you know Richard Feynman said that
the most important question of all or
knowledge of all is the so-called Atomic
hypothesis what sort of wisdom or
knowledge or teaching or Discovery by
human beings would you be comfortable as
representing the most amount of
knowledge and therefore advanced
technology perhaps most magical
invention of human beings
well I think the biggest challenge is to
understand the brain and life itself and
uh this can be be done in a number of
ways and also an astronomer I would hope
that uh if we can discover evidence for
life in other places
which is certainly possible and see what
variety displays that will help us to
understand our place not just on the
Earth but in the by the cosmos so I'm
hopeful of understanding life and uh
intelligence and brains very good and
then the newest of the Fantastic Four
questions that I've added is another
quote from Sir Arthur did you know him
by the way Lord Martin I exchange emails
with him about the the m87 jet was
artificial oh yeah well
I'm a huge fan of his his works but uh
yeah I I didn't ever meet him right well
he said uh Fame he said a lot of things
including
um for every expert there's an equal and
opposite expert he's quite pithy uh but
one of my favorite quotes of his is um
when uh when a distinguished but elderly
scientist states that something is
possible they are almost certainly right
when they State something is impossible
they are very probably wrong I want to
ask you Lord Martin on the off chance
that you're ever wrong about something
uh besides the exact mechanism for CMV
polarization we're not going to hold
that against you but but have you
changed your mind recently or in a
significant way throughout your career
or recently on anything related to
science
um
I haven't really but I think uh what was
A Change Is that many of the challenges
which uh we were
speculating about when I started have
been settled and we're now addressing
questions couldn't even be imposed 50
years ago so that's an indication of the
exciting progress that uh astronomy
cosmology has made in the last 50 years
uh due as I emphasize in my book uh not
to armchair theorists like me but mainly
do much more sophisticated engineering
and far better instruments on the ground
and in space but I think there's been a
huge advance and so the um the problems
that uh I'm thinking about now couldn't
have been posed 50 years ago but I think
there's a lot of truth because
um it's rare for scientists to do their
best work in old age whereas it's quite
common for musicians to produce their
best compositions in their own age and
as I say in my book this is because if
you're a composer then you're influenced
by the Stars when you were young but
then it's internal development where
science is an inherently
Collective activity and so to keep it
the frontier you've got to absorb new
ideas understand new techniques Etc and
that's something you become less good at
as we get older so we've got to stick to
things we can understand and accept our
limitations
very good yeah oh sorry I missed the
last part you said okay so carry on I
guess yeah so yes so keep calm and carry
on as a always a very good British
aphorism uh Lord Martin I want to thank
you as usual for your uh your your very
wonderful contributions to my life my
career but also to the greater
scientific good this wonderful book uh
if science is to save us please
everybody get this book and read this
book engage with it because it's it's
written this year I mean there's it's
not some stale book that was written
before that it's fresh uh and relevant
and pertinent and will have the ability
maybe I'll ask you one more question
Lord Martin
um it said that uh some authors would
rather have
um you know kind of one book read a
hundred years from now then sell 100
books you know one year from which do
you prefer do you prefer your books have
longevity or massive critical and six
and popular success
um well I think many of the questions
I'm addressing are fairly timely yeah
and so we'll be out of date so uh I mean
princess my book called on the future
four years ago was as you say it talks
about pandemics in the abstract yeah
um and uh uh in the paperback which came
out just last year at an extra chapter
of Lessons Learned From covert so I
think um some of the things that I
discuss about how science is done may
still be 200 years from now I don't know
but most of it will be out of date so uh
I expect that um
um I hope there are some sales in the
next year or two but I expect they will
decline although my book just six
numbers yeah has been the most steady
seller for 25 years and I was lucky
because I wrote it just after the last
big number was discovered
choice of six uh now 25 years later all
right uh that's uh and also you know in
some ways led to uh the uh also great
and deserve recognition the Templeton
prize and many other accolades that are
too numerous it would take us another
two hours to read it but Martin I want
to thank you so much for sharing so much
of your time with me and my audience
today and I hope we can be in person
maybe I'll come visit you next year when
I visit the UK for the first time in
three or four years
yeah it's not that bad here
maybe I can poach you Martin I mean come
on we've got great beaches I know you
like to Surf and uh We've we've we've
vetted you in the past and we'll do it
again
um Lord Martin Reese uh thank you so
much
but thank you very much
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
[Music]
[Music]
time
[Music]